Протести, пікети, блокування доріг.
Власники автомобілів на єврономерах,
так званих "євроблях",
вимагають скасувати ухвалені 8 листопада закони,
які, з одного боку, дають право на пільгове
розмитнення автомобілів, а з іншого - передбачають
штрафи за відсутність реєстрації в Україні.
Кілька років держава фактично ігнорувала проблему "євроблях".
Експерти іронізували: українські номерні знаки втрачають сенс
і їх можна просто скасувати.
Влада наважилася навести лад на ринку вживаних авто та встановити правила гри
без сірих "литовських" схем. Автори законів
переконують, що іномарки стануть доступнішими для українців.
Самі ж "євробляхери" так не думають.
Одна з головних вимог протестувальників -
скасувати коефіцієнт віку в розрахунку вартості акцизу.
Приміром, аби ввезти в Україну
дволітрову іномарку на бензині віком 5 років,
потрібно сплатити 500 євро акцизу,
а за таку саму автівку, якій 15 років, - вже 1500 євро.
За логікою авторів закону, це має стимулювати
українців купувати новіші та екологічніші авто.
Однак "євробляхери" стверджують:
середній вік машин в Україні на українських номерах - майже 20 років.
І ці, зокрема, маршрутки, вантажівки, а також ще радянські "жигулі"
значно "брудніші" для екології, ніж 15-річні завезені іномарки.
Утім, насправді проблема не в акцизі чи в інших податках,
а в тому, що переважну більшість автомобілів
на єврономерах взагалі неможливо легалізувати.
Адже розмитнити можна лише те, що належить тобі, а не чужу власність.
Просто техпаспорт на ім’я якогось поляка, литовця
чи громадянина іншої країни, де зареєстрований автомобіль,
не дає права на його легалізацію в Україні.  Тобто спершу чужу власність потрібно
переоформити на себе і зняти з обліку в Польщі, Литві чи іншій країні реєстрації.
Але більшість автомобілів на єврономерах продають посередники.
Це фірми-метелики, які працюють напівлегально і швидко зникають,
щоб недоплачувати податки чи не мати зобов’язань перед клієнтами.
Окрім того, щоб отримати пільговий коефіцієнт на акциз,
потрібно мати договір купівлі-продажу автомобіля.
Більшість українців цього не роблять,
купуючи машини через фірми-посередники.
Ті беруть гроші, дають вам ключі і кажуть,
що автомобіль ваш, хоча насправді за правом власності
він належить зовсім іншій особі.
Експерти сумніваються, що
така пільгова легалізація "євроблях" спрацює.
Нові закони можуть зменшити завезення нових "євроблях",
але навряд чи усунуть проблему з тими, що
вже їздять дорогами України.
За різними оцінками, в Україні від 280 тисяч
до одного мільйона нерозмитнених іномарок.
Багато з них легалізувати через
вищезгадані проблеми не вдасться.
Автомобілі, швидше за все,
доведеться розбирати на запчастини або утилізовувати.